[Music]
not that you asked but if you had I'd
have told you that 48 seconds of Disney
logos were too freakin many seconds even
back in 1991 yes we're sending the
special edition of this movie which
leads me to question
that was wrong with the original version
that made it not special enough for me
as a kid I feel like my whole youth is
in question here once upon a time in a
funny way sir
B once upon a time cliche has been a
cliche since the 1400s which means even
Hans Christian Andersen was probably
tired of writing that book in the 19th
century also narrations although he had
everything his heart desired the prince
was spoiled selfish and unkind yeah but
his family motto is literally a Latin
Maxim that translates to he conquers who
conquers himself and warns against
becoming selfish and unkind not saying
the prince should be perfect but
shouldn't someone be constantly
reminding about that also latin spoiler
a known beggar came to the castle and
offered him single rose in return for
showtimes digit code okay first of all
why is the prince entering the castle
door I know for a fact he has like 300
servants second it's impressive that
there's a stained-glass portrait of
every scene in this interaction with the
old woman so the background looks more
like a thunderstorm than a snowstorm so
I'm immediately calling bullshit on the
old woman story and gotta agree with
Prince Teen Wolf on this one and his
punishment she transformed him into a
hideous piece and preached a powerful
spell on the car
oh damn we know the prince is an asshole
but after turning away this flower
peddling woman once she came up and his
entire staff potentially for ever the
real moral of this story is unless
you're Joel Kinnaman do not with an
enchantress in a magic mirror is his
only window to the outside world except
for you know all the windows was truly
an enchanted Rose which would bloom
until his 21st year if he could learn to
love another then the spell would be
broken he's got to fall in love by the
time he's 21 Jesus even by fairytale
standards that's pretty cool young what
if he wanted to backpack on Europe for a
year volunteer with Greenpeace before
settling down if not he would be doomed
to remain a beast oh god it also sounds
like The Enchantress made the Prince
immortal so it's not that bad of a deal
with the way this chick goes around
arbitrarily handing out punishments it's
pretty likely she also did this to a
princess so at some point they would
probably end up finding each other and
living together forever is too pretty
compatible immortal beasts especially
after kinder is invented I know Bell's
dad is a crackpot inventor but those
gears should not be turning the way
they're turning even Disney Animation
should abide by some sort of practical
physics also the wind is blowing hard
enough for this windmill to be turning
constantly Belle's hair should be moving
to these French towns people speak
mostly English to each other except for
the print words that are almost
universally understood by Americans does
it count even know they have a
bookseller
it's the only sign in English ah borrows
this one yeah but this is a bookseller
bill not a goddamn library
Wow you didn't miss a shot Gaston Gaston
has a great shot but he's hunting right
in the middle of the fucking town aren't
you supposed to do that in a woods long
John is French for money but this shop
seems to specialize in cookware so it
must be one of those punny shops that
means our cookware is still money and we
don't even know it jeez I don't know
what Bill's complaining so much about
this town has a farmers market that
would make a hipster cream in his pants
sure most of them are busy singing but
someone should really tell Belle she's
about to walk out of the movie into a
Monet painting can you read it there's
no pictures actually there's at least
one picture of a time where the hero
meets Prince Charming enak renderware
Disney continues its tradition of mostly
sentient but still not quite talking
horses so far out does the Enchantress's
curse go from the castle is this also
cursed land and could she consult the
town records to make sure she stayed
within the property lines police didn't
notice this enormous gate and the
enormous castle behind the gate until
just now
the Beast has been secretly beating for
ten years before Reese is somehow
unaware of this very nearby castle also
it's super weird the villagers wouldn't
be at all disturbed that the Prince of
the very nearby castle hasn't been seen
or heard from in years and even if this
prince is habitually reclusive you'd
think that someone would know one of the
300 live-in servants and wonder where
they are
right right oh no no nothing masters
yeah at this point Lumiere is just being
a world-class role even if beasts were
fine with taking this dude in for the
night why would you let him sit in his
favorite chair tickle the mama
Cantus in this for something we
shouldn't be hearing from a childlike
character and quietly move on also where
the hell did chip come from if they've
all been enchanted for ten years we have
two options one mrs. Potts as a teapot
gave birth to a cup or two the Beast is
the only person in the castle allowed to
ate either way a strange man is drinking
from a child's head
[Music]
these assholes think what happened has
there ever been a time when the Beast
pleasantly welcome to guests I'll give
you a push today
oh the erstwhile prince didn't even let
the Enchantress through the door but
rather than kicking maurices ass out he
imprisons him up in the tower I guess in
case maurice is a fairytale botanist
Belle's father was whacky and brilliant
enough to invent this contraption
instead of a normal people even though
it functions exactly like normal people
this is the day your dreams come true
what do you know about my dreams guess
Tom I would send this cartoonish blatant
stalking behavior but I'm more concerned
about that giant can pop the fireplace
holy how did I even clean that thing
[Music]
this is clearly what Belle wants but
it's later happy to be sequestered in a
palace with the prince
where is East Indies you have to take me
to a leaf hasn't actually been to the
castle since he freaked out at the cliff
and Maurice had to go the rest of the
way on foot thought he brings bill right
to the gates on this go-around also
Felice would have no idea Maurice went
into the castle he could be hiding in
the leaves or the mud pita style
anywhere in the woods also good thing
the Wolves decided to stop whole thing
while Belle was looking for a pop if
it's just goddamn easy to open this gate
why are these grounds not covered in
wolves Lillian leads Belle to her father
instead of maybe introducing her to the
Beast I mean it eventually works out
that she trades herself for him but was
Lumiere counting on that
and if so that the diabolical King
candlestick right there I want you to
leave this who's done this to you no
time to explain actually there's just
enough time to say a big enchanted beast
man did this to me and that's why you
need to leave since we later see chip
tag along with Belle back to the village
we know the objects are free to go
wherever they want while in magical form
so why haven't they been searching for
some help in breaking the curse for the
last 10 years this is something movie
could have found time to tell us about
instead of showing Lumiere tried to
seduce a feather duster I'm especially
good at ik hawk all ratings Gaston may
not be able to read but he knows the
word expectorating I use antlers in all
of my back already
yes Tom's got an impressive array of
heads of wild boars l can bear so why
did he go to the trouble of mounting a
rabbit and an owl will help
you out oh well know what help me or
eise tries exactly one place to find
help for bail then immediately gives up
I thought you might knock you spotted
two Angela Lansbury is insulting crimes
and cata Cove indisinct careful the
sentient wardrobe has been in the room
the entire time watching Bella cry but
cheerfully announces herself here
isn't that creepier than like just
clearing your throat while she's bawling
her eyes out the Sugar Bowl and creamer
don't have faces were they inanimate
objects that were enchanted to life or
maybe humans that died while they were
objects and are now stuck in a hellish
purgatory of porcelain servitude that
was a very brave thing you did Nadia we
all think so I could buy the missus
pathes heard the gossip about Belle's
bargain for her death but how the hell
did the Wardrobe find out about it since
she's been stuck in the bedroom this
whole time was a human again by midnight
oh no baby you me everything staked on
ya like two to three days at most she
doesn't eat with me and she doesn't eat
at all after being spurned at the dinner
table beast decides to get bill a good
old-fashioned Code Red show me the girl
on demand magical voyeurism she'll never
see me as anything Lobster
dramatic flower wilting is grammatically
whoopi attempted forcible cable thickens
Lumiere cordially gives Belle a
third-degree burn she's not a prisoner
she's our guest she's literally a
prisoner by all means feed her well but
she's a prisoner okay that curse of the
Enchantress turned all the staff and the
furniture neat insults but there are a
lot of individual plates and teacups and
such does that mean that all of them
were previously human if so that's an
enormous step even for a large castle
and if not what happens to the Animus
dinnerware when the curse is lifted is
this table a human I have so many
questions based on the clothing firearms
and steam engine technology this movie
takes place sometime in mid to late 18th
century but the Eiffel Tower wasn't
constructed until about a hundred years
later in 1887
I am gone Gombe they have this amount of
fresh food it means that either one of
the magical creatures regularly goes to
the village market or there's a poor
bastard delivery man who's seen some
weird this castle ten years we've been
rushed to hang up ten years and the
prince had until his 21st birthday to
find love so he has to still be 20 this
means the Enchantress cursed a 10 year
old for being mean to her also I'm not
saying that excuses him for being a
kidnapping tipper case but he clearly
had few positive role models in his life
just a horny candle or Glock who won't
disagree with him and a teapot who
ignores 19 of her 20 children we
interrupt this fantastic musical number
to briefly bring you a screensaver from
windows 3.0 this song is just one of the
greatest Disney musical numbers of all
time I'm smiling so widely I must remove
three things although this song is
responsible for disney world's annoying
ad campaign that's constantly run over
the following several decades so I'll
add one back heyyyyyy sinners gotta send
yo oh I couldn't possibly go to bed now
especially considering she's had like
three bites from that entire fucking
meal bear with this oh no absolutely
nothing of interest at all in the West
Wing get Cogsworth and Lumiere just say
hey beasties up there and you probably
don't want to disturb it damn the Beast
Charles Foster Kane dug out of this room
Thomas oh no Thomas I can't stay here
another minute well couldn't she have
done this from the get-go if she doesn't
give a shit about the promise and it's
easy to just walk the hell out the front
door what took her so long wait Elise
the horse has been patiently waiting
outside the castle this whole time in a
blizzard I don't care how fantastically
animated your fantastically animated
movie is Disney there is no way been
able to get beast up on that horse by
yourself well you shouldn't have been in
the West Wing well you should learn to
control your temper oh look there
angrily shouting that must mean they're
falling in love I've never felt this way
about any
okay Belle got to the castle yesterday
to rescue Maurice had dinner attempted
escape got rescued and bandaged old
beastie last night so beast has
literally fall in love in less than 24
hours
sounds more like Lobster infatuation to
me and the Rose should disallow this
bullshit also since we hit puberty the
only females he's been around or a
teapot a feather duster and a wardrobe
I'm glad he never felt this way before
also I guess it's helpful but the first
female to show up at his cursed castle
in ten years is the hottest girl in the
village am i right me I never seen so
many books in all my life
yeah but I hope you're not interested in
anything on the top you rose once those
are impossible to reach these goes from
filthy to fresh then back to filthy in
less than ten seconds flat and now he
I'm so unsure I wonder why I didn't see
it before I'm gonna go with probably
because we imprisoned my father then
traded my father's life for mine and was
consistently emotionally abusive to me
during the first day I knew it hey maybe
something do you think what fancy fool
what fair mama
thank you but couldn't mrs. Potts just
tell chip they may be following along I
don't think you have to be of a certain
age to be able to handle that
information unless she's insinuating
that they might bone later tonight which
I guess is an alarming possibility why
I'm human again only human again special
edition of movie includes a song that's
a little more human league than they may
have intended I know they're psyched
about the possible love connection but
making a big deal about how the dead
looks is a little presumptuous a
unnecessary musical number is secretly
just an excuse to do a Fantasia callback
but didn't remind viewers to go ahead
and drugged up before watching this
movie
so does time damn Angela Lansbury does a
terrible Celine Dion impression
also what about this story is as old as
time imprisoning your potential mate
repeatedly threatening her and cutting
her off from her family if that's the
case I'm gonna have to rethink my
wedding vows Jesus this shot is amazing
it's like a great camera technique from
an actual movie and this is animated and
it's from 1991 three more sends off
before I get too excited he's finally
learnt enough that's it then I should
break the spell it's not enough she has
to love him in return
how the hell does Lumiere not know this
by now only listening to the narration
at the beginning of the movie it's all
right papa
I'm home can we talk about what a couple
aureus is in this movie first he blows
the house up in preparation for the fair
then gets lost on the way to it that
he's responsible for the eventual
imprisonment of bail during the moment
bail could find true happiness with
Beast she witnesses his epic fail at
trying to get back to the castle and his
erratic behavior is the catalyst to gas
Tom's plan to marry Belle why do we like
this character again is it because of
the moustache it is an adorable ass -
come to collect your father my father
don't worry that was you it Gaston pay
off the whole town there were they just
super eager to form a mob and Chuck more
ease into the loony bit highway bobbies
these villagers were literally just
mocking the idea that beasts existed but
are now all jazzed up to go kill him I
guess they already had the torches in
the pitchforks so might as well add a
murder into the schedule pieces will
make off with your children my the
health of the villagers bring their kids
to come see more he's committed Hey it
took Maurice almost the whole day to get
to the enchanted woods and that was on
horseback that this village horde can
make it up there within minutes before
the quarters go out what should we know
pessimistic beasts and where to find
them
chips a teacup that has the brain of a
child and no appendages whatsoever is
able to get this contraption working
[Music]
thankfully the horrific mutilation of
this man's face occurs off screen kind
of pervy motherfucker gets off on
plucking and anthropomorphize feather
duster Disney used to have some sick
bastards working for them and I don't
just mean Michael Eisner
Gaston just happened to satisfy his
killing boner with in full view of belt
can we just pick a size for Beast
he looked almost human size when he was
dancing with Belle but here he's got
enormous neck and back muscles that
would make bein jealous yeah but only to
warn you about the unhinged mob about to
attack the castle I'm pretty sure unless
you somehow turn into a prince or
something she's probably gonna head back
to the village now no one lies like
Gaston
no one dies like Gaston can exemplify
boneheaded dicks like Gaston
spirit fingers see Disney eyes reverse
transformation is basically a diet
American Werewolf in London sure he
looks better than he did it as the beast
but that's the prince I mean I know he's
rich and she loves him and everything
but I think the animators blew their
beauty budget on belt yeah it's neat
Belle seems like she doesn't believe
this dude is the Beast even though he
transformed right before her very eyes
why the hell did the rest of the curse
takes so long to reverse the prince was
transformed for over a minute before the
magic fireworks went off does it have to
wait until they kiss to make sure it was
true long and if so what would have
happened if they just held hands instead
to say knots it fits the Brits even
though he's print size now and not beast
size this movie perspective so much that
this could all be playing out in a
miniature dollhouse and I wouldn't be
surprised nah man you do not want to be
on the receiving end of a Lumiere climax
after he's been pent up for 10 years
see animators got through that last joke
about chip sleeping in the cupboard and
must have left the rest of the work to a
drunken third grader in case you missed
literally the last refrain in the movie
five seconds ago here's the pop version
of
thank God quiet
redneck hold on who are you what are you
doing here just my heart what Bell's
gonna get the surprise of her life I
guess not
sorry I'm sleeping Tommy
[Music]
[Applause]
can you hear me we talk about anything
I'm not fortune
[Music]
we have asked with the tapestry stadium
all doing that this is a castle isn't it
there are a tapestry this is a castle
and we have many tapestries